so we just heard from kate green there
saying that labour want to see this two
to three weeks circuit breaker to give
us some breathing space to get on top of
test and trace
people want to know is that gonna happen
no
absolutely not well i've just listened
to kate and i've got great respect for
her
but what she completely failed to answer
is the reason why we should have
restrictions
in parts of the country where the
infection rate is low
um when what we need to do is to make
sure that in those areas where the
infection rate is high
that we protect people from reinfection
sadly the case in the northwest
is that the the number of people who are
catching the disease the number of
people who are going into hospital
the number of people uh who uh
tragically are dying
has been increasing we need to take
steps there
uh the mayor of liverpool joe anderson
the liverpool merseyside city region
mayor steve rotherham
the leaders of lancashire council
they've all recognized that they've
accepted these
restrictions and they've also worked
with central government in order to make
sure
that there is a package of support and i
think that's right
but it would seem to me to be um
[Music]
an error to try to impose on every part
of the country
the same level of restriction when we
know that the disease
is uh spreading more intensively and
quicker
in some parts of the country the nature
of the
epidemiology the scientific word for the
spread of the disease
is different in this wave than it was
earlier in the year so just to be clear
are you saying that you're ruling it out
now or you're ruling it out
at any point well we always look at how
the disease
spreads and we'll take whatever steps
are necessary
to maintain public health but uh kate
um and the labour party are arguing for
blanket restrictions
across the country at the moment and the
spread and the nature of the disease
does not merit that approach at the
moment okay and it would seem to me to
be
uh wrong to uh impose restrictions on
the economic and personal life
of individuals and parts of the country
where the disease is not spreading
so intensively and and one of the things
i have enormous respect for kate
but one of the things that many people
will wonder is why did labour argue for
this this week
kate in a different context had said
that the labour party should
regard the coronavirus epidemic as a
good crisis
which should not go to waste something
and then he's apologized for
that she's ashamed of and she's no no i
i've gone over the
i understand that and as i say i've got
great respect for kate
but kierstalmer seems to me to be
someone who
uh you know his political career
seems to be built on shifting sands
taking a position
whenever it suits him and many people
will uh will ask
why is it that he's calling for this
lockdown now
when his own mayor in greater manchester
andy burnham is uh is fighting against
these measures okay many people would
say that
uh if labor are serious about the nhs
and about this disease
then kier would be calling on andy
burnham and inviting andy burnham
to accept the need for these measures
you've we've talked about labor there
let's talk about the government and the
government's response
because that the counter argument is
that if you act swiftly
and decisively then further action
later down the line won't be necessary i
just want to have a look at what sir
patrick valencia chief scientific
adviser said on friday he said
it is important to go quite fast on this
it's important to make sure that you go
hard enough to get the r below one the
sooner you do that the more you get this
under control
for many the lesson of the first
lockdown was that we didn't
act fast enough we did it and as a
result we had to lock down
longer and for harder are we making the
same mistake now
well they're making that mistake in
manchester yes because uh it's perfectly
clear
from the uh the response the right
response
from uh the uh the mayor of liverpool
and local government leaders in
lancashire
they recognize there's a particular
situation in the northwest
that requires action um but in in
greater manchester
sadly um uh those steps have not yet
been taken
we're ready to do everything we can
whatever it takes are you ready to
help people in manchester saying you're
already
ready to do everything it takes is that
does that mean you you are willing to
impose
greater restrictions on greater
manchester even if andy burnham resists
well one of the reasons why we've been
talking to local government leaders
is that we believe that a partnership
approach is best
we could have imposed um measures before
now
but we've talked are you ready to do it
in the future well we want to reach an
agreement but
the the real question is for the
uh the civic political leadership
political action is a better word
the political leadership in greater
manchester um
are are you ready to impose restrictions
if
the political leadership in greater
manchester continues to resist well i
want to give them the opportunity i want
to be fair to them
to recognize that this is a public
health crisis
um and that there are a very
straightforward question are you ready
to impose
if they don't if they continue to resist
it's a it's a question in a context
and the context is this that i want to
reach an agreement with the political
leadership
in greater manchester i want them to
put aside for a moment some of the
political positioning
that they've indulged in and i want them
to work with us
in order to ensure that we save lives
and protect the nhs because an absence
of action
will mean and sir patrick is absolutely
right an absence of action will mean
more people get infected as more people
get infected that will place
more pressure on the nhs and the more
people
sadly um in intensive care beds
in the northwest and in manchester who
are suffering from coronavirus
the fewer intensive care beds are there
for people with other
serious conditions all this is happening
as we move closer
to the winter and instead of you know
um press conferences and
posturing what we need is action
to save people's lives you're very
critical at their
press conferences posturing being
politically indulgent you're
very critical there uh yes uh some of
the uh political leaders uh
in the regions including greater
manchester united but at the same
let me finish my question if you will
thank you well i'll i'll respond to your
point because i think there's a
there's a clear difference between the
approach that's been taken
in liverpool yeah already yeah and these
are civic
between the lines andy burnham and yet
you can understand
his perspective people in the city that
he represents have been under
restrictions for 11 weeks they haven't
worked cases are still going up
it's been incredibly difficult for
people to have to make these sacrifices
you're asking them to uh to basically
swallow further restrictions
restrictions
even your own scientific advisors have
questioned whether they'll be enough to
bring the virus under control
and if they are unable to work they only
get two-thirds
of their salaries is that really a fair
way to treat people in greater
manchester
and can you not understand why some of
the political leaders might be trying to
stand up
and asking for more from the government
for the people that they represent
well let's take each of those steps um
where is the scientific evidence
where are the scientific voices saying
that it's wrong to have these additional
restrictions in manchester
i haven't heard them um the the fact is
that whether it's a patrick valance
chris whittie
or others people recognize that when you
have a high
rate of virus infection you need
additional restrictions but they are
saying tier three i'm reading from
patrick valens here tier three baseline
conditions on their own almost certainly
aren't enough to get they are below one
so they're saying that the tier three
won't even work
no um well they are saying that tier
three
plus local measures will work the reason
that we're talking to the
political leadership in manchester is
that we're saying um
we want additional measures you know
that they will work
let's work together as we have in other
parts of the northwest to do that
uh the political leadership in greater
manchester is resisting
precisely the program that will bring
the virus down
now you ask quite rightly of course
about the economic support package as
well
the economic support package that we've
negotiated with other parts of the north
west
is there in order to help individuals
and to help businesses
and the money that we're providing is uh
more generous
than comparable schemes in comparable
european countries
and i don't think anyone underestimates
the scale of concern that we all have
about this
but it is better for the economy as you
yourself
pointed out earlier that we act quickly
if we don't act quickly
to deal with the spread of the virus
then it's not just the health it's also
that the economic consequences
are worse so it's a false argument
to say that uh time spent resisting
the uh the um these measures is
somehow fighting for greater
manchester's economy for jobs and
livelihoods
it's not it is time wasted
when we should be taking the appropriate
measures to protect
public health because you know the the
government's actions here
are driven by an overwhelming desire to
to make sure that we save lives okay in
greater manchester
and elsewhere and and that's why um
the the chancellor of the exchequer the
health secretary have been
uh the community secretary have been
engaging in this process
because we want to help and and in
liverpool
again you know um there have been some
tough decisions that the mayor there and
the
the metro mayor have had to swallow but
they've done the right thing
now and and we should recognize that and
and we should you know
people like joe anderson in liverpool
who
um i want to talk about the elephant in
the room
restrictions only work if people follow
the rules yes and i notice that uh
police are going to be giving details of
people told to
self-isolate i mean it seems that that
is a pretty
obvious admission that there are people
who are not obeying the rules what do
your figures on compliance show
well it is the case sadly and again it
varies that there has been a
um a problem with compliance and
um a challenge on enforcement uh uh but
again
um some of the steps that we've taken
have been designed to help with that
what do the figures show because you
must have figures on compliance
why why aren't you sharing them with us
well i think again
there are uh there are local figures and
uh it varies from area to area
but so just give us a few examples and
what what do they show well
one of the things they show is that um
uh there have been cases
legitimate cases where people have felt
that not confined
would cause them some economic uh
hardship
and to be fair to the
local leaders across the united kingdom
including the scottish government
they made the case um and we absolutely
agreed
that providing financial support for
people who had to self-isolate
was appropriate and this is an example
why don't you
genuinely interested why are you not
releasing the figures on compliance
well again some of these figures depend
on uh what's happening between the
police and what's happening between
individuals is it because you're worried
that people look at them think wow
that's really low i'm not going to
bother following the rules either no
because i think most of us recognize
that it is a good idea to follow the
rules
but we're ready to support and again you
know one of the points that i i i think
it's important to recognize
is where you've got um political leaders
with whom i
might disagree um like uh nicholas
sturgeon or mark brakeford
who uh appreciate the pressure
on the nhs they are doing everything
they can
in order to try to ensure that the rules
are enforced and
you know nicola recognizes in scotland
that you need slightly different rules
in glasgow than you do
um in the highlands but she also has
worked with us
in order to provide an economic support
package could there be more money
available to
try and make sure people do self-isolate
well we're always keeping under review
the support package that we need one of
the reasons so yes that could
potentially be
then one of the things again you can you
can quite rightly run through a variety
of different areas where perhaps
potential financial support
might be helpful but my view is that the
best way of doing that
is to work with other civic leaders
in different parts of the country to
analyze what might be required
that's what we've always done um that's
what we will continue
to do but but again we all will all
we can only provide that support if we
keep a balanced approach
and we also recognize that in those
parts of the country where we don't need
restrictions
economic life should continue as close
to normal as possible very quickly
because i'm keen to talk to you a bit
about brexit as well
um tony blair has been accused of uh
breaching these
uh self-isolating rules after returning
uh from abroad now a spokesperson said
we believe he followed all the
guidelines as advised he was not refused
exemption by the uk government are you
going to be looking into this
not me personally no i'm i'm sure that
the there will be people who will
scrutinize what happened
uh but um do you think it's right for
people to have a look to see if he did
obey the rules
i think i think it's right for everyone
to have that but all i would say
is that while there are many things that
anybody did that i disagreed with he's
played a distinguished role in helping
to bring peace to parts of the middle
east recently
um and so i shall be criticizing him
until there is strong evidence
that merrick said okay now i want to
talk about brexit
because earlier this month you said that
there was a 66 percent chance
a trade deal would be struck with the eu
what do you put the chances at now
less how much less less than 50 percent
well i think uh uh it's less i do
i can't be precise but one of the
reasons why it's less
is the position that's been taken in the
last couple of weeks by
european union leaders what we've seen
and what our negotiators have found
is that the european union side have not
been willing to
produce the the detailed legal text
they've not been willing to
intensify the talks in a way that uh
would indicate that they were
actually serious about reaching
agreement and at the same time
they've also insisted both that we
accept a level of um control over our
autonomy
that an independent country can't really
accept
and at the same time they're saying that
they should continue to have exactly the
same access
to for example our fishing waters and
our fishing stocks
as before um and so you know that that
seems to me to be
the uh the behavior of an organization
and an institution
that is not serious about making the
compromises necessary to secure a deal i
still
hope we'll get a deal with it so are the
talks still happening
what's going on is michelle barney going
to be coming next week who you're having
the talks
well the ball's in his court um uh we've
made clear
that we need to see a change in approach
from the european
union i know that he'll be calling
david frost over the course of the next
few days
let's see if the european union
appreciate
the importance of reaching a deal and
the importance of moving ground i mean
it's pretty clear that you feel that
they need to move further but we do have
to look at the impact that uh
not reaching a trade deal could have on
the united kingdom as yourself i said
it's gonna be quite considerable
reasonable worst case scenario without
more preparation there could be queues
of up to
7 000 lorries in kent are we really
willing to risk that over
fishing which is clearly a very very
important thing for a lot of people but
it represents what
0.12 of the economy well again two
things i'd say the first thing about
publishing a reasonable worst case
scenario
is that we published it in order to show
what would happen if we weren't fully
prepared
since then government has been doing
more but in fact
there's probably six thousand laura
kennedy in particular business has been
doing um a great deal more
they've been fantastic business leaders
uh from richard burnett the
leader of the road all the justices less
than a month ago you said less than a
quarter of businesses were fully ready
yeah
um to adam marshall at the chambers of
commerce who have been and karen
fairbairn of the cbi
who've been working with us to help
businesses to get ready
and again one of the things about
businesses being ready for um
a uh an australia style departure is
that businesses
if they take the australia style leaving
without a deal let's let's call a spade
of spades
the australia doesn't have a leaving
without a free trade agreement but we
have a deal we have a withdrawal
agreement
one of the reasons um why that's
important is that it settles the rights
of uk citizens and so on
but to cut to the quick um whatever
outcome we get in these negotiations um
there are levels of preparation that we
need to make because we're going to be
outside the customs union and outside
the single market
and taking those preparations also
enable businesses to take advantage
of the new trade deals that we're
concluding like the trade deal that liz
trust has concluded with japan
that gives us better access to the
world's third largest economy than we
did when we were in
the eu the thing is it's going to be
quite hard isn't it
to separate the economic disruption
caused by clover 19
and any further economic disruption
caused by
leaving the transition period without a
trade deal you know a cynic would say
that it almost gives you cover to play
tough and go for no deal
no um i want a deal i'm
keen to conclude one um but it takes
both sides
to um compromise in order for there to
be one
the eu side is not doing so at the
moment
um and if the choice is between um
accepting a deal in which our hands are
tied and we don't have control
over our own waters
or leaving and being clear that we're
honoring the mandate that the british
people gave us to take back control then
we have to take back control